(banjo music)
- People don't realize,
when they walk outside,
there's basically a grocery
store surrounding them.
And that's such a beautiful
thing about nature.
A lot of my job is to
walk around in the woods
and say, oh, what is that in the ground?
Pick it up and eat it.
I have this sort of curious nature
where I never am satisfied with something.
If we're cooking something,
how can we do it better?
How can you make it more interesting?
We have to eat, as human beings,
so why not make it the most
memorable experience you can?
My name is James Gop.
I'm a culinary artist,
forager, and founder of Heirloom Fire.
More often than not, we're
working with clients,
executing their vision.
So, I'm incredibly
flattered that Coors Light
wants to let us create a dinner
that we'll be doing later this week
where we are building
a menu designed around
native species, what's
growing in that moment.
The Berkshires have a little bit
of a reputation for a reason.
We're a little bit more north,
so the growing seasons are so short.
So it's really about
embracing that moment in time.
Viewing it as, when the iron's
hot, you have to strike.
- [Chris] The thing about
James is he never stops.
- Chris, look at this, man.
All the wild grape vines.
Should you, just like
we've been talking about.
It even has a sweet quality to it.
- He holds himself at such a high standard
that when he gets to where his dream is,
his own standard goes up.
That's very inspiring, in a way,
because it pushes you to
just continue to be better,
and continue to be better.
- [James] My largest form of inspiration
is going into woods.
It makes me feel like this warmth in my chest
and the hair stand up
on the back of my neck,
and I want to be able to
share that with people.
That's my artistic expression,
to be able to replicate
that moment in time.
It's usually about a 17-hour day onsite.
It's a big experience
where you have to love it.
And thankfully, I have that in a team.
So we're onsite now.
I'm hoping, today, to
get a hold of some stuff
we weren't able to get due to
the massive rain last night.
Wow, this is the first hen
of the woods I've ever found.
We'll break off all the little
sort of petals here
and just sauté them in a lot
of butter and a lot of salt
and just fold them in with the vegetables.
- So I was out in the woods;
came across these little red berries
that taste remarkably like black pepper.
- Let's put them in a dish tonight.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you very much for coming.
My goal is to, really, forever
change your lives today.
I want to have everybody take this moment
where they're just being here, present,
and realizing that these
aren't just weeds and grasses,
but looking around and thinking of, wow,
that's actually like an edible
grocery store out there.
I love the theater of what we do.
That's something that I want
to be able to give people.
The theater, the entertainment,
exposing them to something
they've never seen.
Really, having a moment in life
that people are gonna walk away from,
and it'll be a memory that's
burned inside of them forever.
As you see, obviously, there's
ice cream involved here,
but this is birchwood ice cream.
It's made by infusing
slices of birchwood,
and cream, milk and sugar overnight.
And if you look above you,
we've actually foraged pine bark,
and then put it into whole wheat flower.
So these are little beignets.
Did you enjoy everything?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah?
Great.
(crowd clapping)
Thank you, again, for making time.
Sincerely, it really
means everything to us
that you come and be a
part of this experience.
I just want to open your
eyes back to nature,
because there's so much
that we've forgotten.
So thank you again for all coming,
and I just want to take a
moment to thank Coors Light
for giving us the opportunity
to tell our story.
Cheers.
(crowd cheering)
(bottles rattling)